good morning believe nation today's
message is do better than you did before
over to you gene Simmons I wake up every
mood latest recipe me go because you
want inspiration look to your mother you
bet don't listen to the self-help gurus
and the people stuff even though I get
paid a lot of money to do this stuff
myself turn around and look at your mom
that's the most inspiration that's the
reason you should go out there and
strive I remember the first 10 million
dollar check I ever made and it came in
at one lumped under the another check
and I gave it to my mother and I said
mom look cuz you know I want my mom to
be really proud and she said in her
broken English we're gonna hold on a
second and she said in her broken
English von der for because she that's
you know she's Hungarian vonderful Tegan
Estella that's Greek one there for now
what are you going to do that's
precisely the point you did well now go
on if you're the fastest human being in
the face of the planet when all the
cameras leave and when the girls stop
kissing you and you put the award away
are you going to get up the next morning
when when the Sun is just coming up and
all by yourself try to break your own
record even though you're the fastest on
earth the idea is shouldn't life be
about striving there is no such a thing
as winning there's only doing better
than you did before because once you
give up you're just waiting to die so
what do you think
I love this because I think if the goal
of mine try and prove myself every day
every time I ride some coffee I want to
be better I want to learn my mistakes
and so that's what I think that's so
great yeah I think a lot of people you
can pay yourselves to people who are a
lot further ahead of you and that's a
great way to model success you know for
example you're trying to launch a
YouTube channel it's not fair to compare
yourself to me who's done it for years
and have a team of people helping me and
because you can't meet that standard you
feel like you're not doing well you're
failing it's great to be able to learn
from people the model success you may
take something from me and something
from other people and put it to use to
make your channel better but I think too
often people compare themselves to
people who have done a lot more and then
they get discouraged they stop the most
important thing is do better then you
did before write yourself to yourself
you make a video the next video should
just be better than the one that you
just made it doesn't have to be at a
level that is unsustainable at this
point one day you'll get there with
practice kaizen every day getting better
hello so the question that a today is
what have you done lately to improve
yourself what have you done lately to
improve yourself leave it in the
comments below and we're going to join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
today's message is do you better than
you oh man that was terrible ok was the
finger was it what's it it's right here
where is what is this adventure kids
playground is lit up brightly at night
for some reason